the EU and the United States have urged
Balkan neighbors Kosovo and Serbia to
immediately de-escalate tensions on
their border Kosovo closed its biggest
crossing a day after protesters blocked
it on the Serbian side serbs in Northern
Kosovo have also erected barricades
tensions have been running High since
last month when Serb Representatives
left State institutions in Kosovo amid a
dispute over license plates
usually bustling with trucks this Border
Station in northeastern Kosovo is
deserted
the largest crossing point to serbio for
now it's been shut down
in response to roadblocks set up by
Kosovo serbs
the minority group makes up less than 10
percent of kosovo's population they
accuse the government there of
discriminating against them but the
blockades are a nuisance for many Kosovo
residents who have to take long detours
to enter or exit the country
the government in Pristina says it won't
put up with this
the establishment of barricades is
illegal unacceptable and will not be
tolerated we have given NATO's Kosovo
forces the necessary time and space to
act but time is running out barricades
that prevent free movement cannot stand
for it
NATO's Kosovo forces are urging calm
from both sides but on Monday Serbia's
President ordered his army to stand
fully ready for combat he also visited
Barracks at the border and accused
Kosovo and the west of stalking tensions
all of you you want conflict you want
serbs to be killed you will be glad if
serbs get killed
Kosovo and Serbia fought a war more than
20 years ago Kosovo then declared its
independence in 2008 something Serbia
does not recognize
tensions between the two countries are
often High the latest wave of protests
was triggered by the arrest of a former
police official in Kosovo he stands
accused of assaulting kosovo's police
but a court and Pristina has released
him into house arrest
many hope this will Defuse The Situation
and perhaps bring calm to the region
even if only for a short time
and I'm very pleased to welcome Edward
at P Joseph he was Deputy head of the
osce mission in Kosovo and he's credited
with having averted a violent
confrontation between Serbia and Kosovo
in April 2012. welcome and thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
us how concerned are you by these
developments that we've been seeing
well look it's a volatile situation but
uh it's a recurring crisis it's uh it's
the same crisis it's very similar to The
Crisis that we had when I was in Kosovo
a decade ago uh when we saw barricades
that lasted uh for months uh this is the
same crisis it's the dispute between
Serbia and Kosovo it's uh kosovo's
attempt to assert and establish
administrative control throughout its
territory including the north uh where
serbs have a dominant position and it's
belgrade's refusal to recognize kosovo's
sovereignty and its territorial
integrity and its manipulation of the
population in the north the coastal
population who are the real victims here
the pawns caught uh in the middle please
well in these in this same crisis Serbia
has now put its Army on its highest
alert do you think that that is just
saber rattling or could we actually see
Serbian troops crossing the border
well uh it's unlikely we would see
Serbian troops across the border but
that doesn't mean that this isn't a very
serious and provocative act and really
uh this crisis has uh two parts it's
it's the actions of the parties uh uh
particularly Belgrade which is uh
escalated and it's the very weak
response by the U.S EU and in this case
also NATO that uh actually encourages uh
the Serbian autocratic President
Alexander to take these steps for
example uh the US and EU today issued a
statement where they suggested that
putting up these barricades is a form of
legitimate peaceful protest
a U.S Senior U.S official said that
Serbia has the right to ask for its
troops to enter into Kosovo when
everyone knows that it's NATO forces the
k-4 force that is solely responsible uh
ultimately for uh Security in Kosovo
well and uh we see that data also
suggests that Serbia has a right to take
this provocative step of bringing forces
uh close to the Border it may have that
right but these steps are highly
provocative and they do not contribute
to the restraint that the U.S EU and
NATO say they want to see please so in
your view then what
these tensions you yourself have been
involved in previous negotiations
between Belgrade and Christina
yes uh okay look there's steps that uh
the the U.S EU and NATO need to take in
the immediate sense but then there's
also the larger problem which is
actually very straightforward it's not a
complicated problem this isn't some
intractable uh dispute that has no
solution it has a very clear solution in
the immediate term the us at EU when
they speak to the parties they have to
remember that both sides are listening
they cannot just send signals of a
softness towards Belgrade without
knowing that those are also listened to
in Pristina the capital of the Republic
of Kosovo so uh it's very important that
they that they send a signal equal
signal of uh intolerance for
provocations and uh for these kinds of
steps and that both ulex and NATO assert
their presence in the north and make it
clear that uh the real issue here the uh
the the the real immediate issue is a
question of rule of law and that there
can be need no tolerance for breaking a
rule of law and that message has to be
sent consistently and equally to both
sides not just cow Towing to Belgrade
because of the leverage it has and
that's ultimately uh the the problem
here the real problem the reason these
crises uh continue uh with such
regularity is because Belgrade has no
interest in resolving this dispute
Serbia owns The Leverage over this
problem and until that Leverage is taken
away and we explain this by the way in a
report by my University Johns Hopkins
seis at Wilson Center a year ago from
crisis to convergence we explained that
until Serbia doesn't have this Leverage
The Leverage that's given to it by the
NATO countries that do not recognize
Kosovo these crises will continue please
well thank you very much for taking the
time to speak with us we're going to
leave it there I'm afraid that was
Edward p Joseph former deputy head of
the osce mission in Kosovo